في شهر تاريخي للاضرابات في بريطانيا يبدا
الاضراب الاكثر انذارا بالخطر والاكثر
اثاره لقلق المرضى وعائلاتهم يضربوا عشرات
الالاف من الممرضين في انجلترا ووينز
وايلاند الشماليه في احتجاج هو الاكبر في
تاريخ قطاع الصحه البريطاني بعد رفض
الحكومه مطالب الممرضين بزياده رواتبهم
بنسبه 19% وهي نسبه تعتبرها الحكومه اعلى
من قدره تحملها
وصفها الممرضون بالمهينه بحقهم باعتبار
انهم اكثر الموظفين التضررا خلال الرائحه
كورونا فيما توعد رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
ريشي سوناك بفرض قوانين جديده للحد من
الاضطرابات وضمان الحد الادنى من مستويات
الخدمه
يوم ما اسوي هكذا وصف العديد الحاله التي
وصلت اليها بريطانيا التي تعاني من اوضاع
المعيشيه سيئه يشعر بها العديد من
المقيمين والعاملينا هنا
الاضراب باستخفاف ولاسيما الممرضين
الممرضين على الخط الامامي طوال الوقت
ليس كافيا وانهم بحاجه الى القيام بشيء
اكثر جواريا
نحن مرهقون للغايه ونعاني من نقص في عدد
الموظفين منذ سنوات عديده وبشكل عام منذ
كوفيد
فنحو 50,000 وظيفه شاغره يعاني من نقصها
قطاع التمريض ما يعني تكدس اعداد المرضى
على لوائح الانتظار الذين وصلت اعدادهم
الى سبعه ملايين ومن المتوقع ان تطول
اللائحه من لندن عروب عبد الحق العربيه